-By day, she is
a camp activities leader
from Myrtle Beach,
South Carolina.
But by night, she's
a Dolly Parton tribute artist
and winner of
"Clash of the Cover Bands."
Here to perform a medley
of Dolly Parton hits,
Karen Hester!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, hello, everybody!
Woo-hoo!
♪ I tumble outta bed
and I stumble to the kitchen ♪
♪ Pour myself
a cup of ambition ♪
♪ Yawnin' and stretchin'
and try to come to life ♪
♪ I jump in the shower
and the blood starts pumpin' ♪
♪ Out on the streets,
the traffic starts jumpin' ♪
♪ With folks like me on the job
from 9 to 5, yeah ♪
♪ Working 9 to 5,
what a way to make a living ♪
♪ Barely gettin' by, it's all
taking and no giving ♪
♪ They just use your mind and
they never give you credit ♪
♪ It's enough to drive you
crazy if you let it ♪
♪ 9 to 5, well, they got you
where they want you ♪
♪ There's a better life ♪
♪ Y'all dream about it,
don't you? ♪
♪ It's a rich man's game ♪
♪ I don't care
what they call it ♪
♪ And you spend your life
putting money in his wallet ♪
♪ 9 to 5 ♪
[ "Jolene" plays ]
♪ Jolene, Jolene,
Jolene, Jolene ♪
♪ I'm begging of you,
please don't take my man ♪
♪ Jolene, Jolene,
Jolene, Jolene ♪
♪ Please don't take him
just because you can ♪
♪ Jolennnne ♪
Woo! Let's party!
♪ Two doors down, they're
laughing and having a party ♪
♪ Yeah, two doors down they're
not aware that I'm around ♪
♪ But here I am just crying my
heart out, feeling sorry ♪
♪ But they're having a party
just two doors down ♪
Let's party!
♪ Oh-oh-oh, whoa,
two doors down ♪
♪ Whoa-ho-ho, two doors ♪
♪ Dooooowwwnnn ♪
Woo-hoo!
-Oh, my goodness!
That was how you do it,
right there!
Thank you so much!
-Thank you so much, Jimmy!
-Karen Hester, right there!
-And happy birthday
to Dolly Parton!
-Happy birthday to Dolly.